jurassic world dominion is ready to
conquer the world and depending on who
you ask that might be a bad thing
critics have seen the jurassic park
super sequel and not everyone likes what
they saw
we made a terrible mistake when michael
crichton first wrote his novel jurassic
park back in 1990 he probably didn't
imagine that it would become a cinematic
franchise that would keep audiences
coming back for decades after the first
trilogy of movies ended with 2001's
jurassic park 3. it looked like that was
it for the likes of alan grant ellie
sattler and ian malcolm but like the
very dinosaurs themselves universal
revived the franchise in 2015 for
jurassic world which centered on an
improved supposedly safer version of the
park of course those safety measures
once again couldn't contain these
prehistoric beasts and the end of its
sequel jurassic world fallen kingdom
drastically changed the status quo of
the entire planet as dinosaurs escaped
out of a northern californian compound
to truly walk the earth this poses a
tantalizing question what would the
modern world look like if dinosaurs
roamed free obviously this idea is at
the very heart of the franchise and it's
clear that these creatures are such a
powerful force that it's almost
impossible for humans to coexist with
them jurassic world dominion is here to
escalate things even further the
trailers from the sequel promised a
globetrotting adventure with owen grady
and claire dearing racing through
different continents trying to escape
giant beasts and just to make things
more exciting sam neal laura dern and
jeff goldblum are all returning to their
roles from the original movie
thankfully the first reactions from
critics recently arrived online so let's
take a look at whether jurassic world
dominion is worth your time or if it's a
giant pile of dino dung
why do they always have to go bigger
unfortunately a lot of critics weren't
impressed by director colin trevorrow's
second jurassic world outing with many
blasting it for his simple plot and
poorly thought out character arcs
obviously the main draw here is the
dinosaurs and the carnage they're
inevitably going to cause but a
captivating human story is necessary to
make audiences care about the action
unfolding on screen gizmodo and io9
reporter jermaine lucier called it the
worst entry in the entire franchise
saying it's too long it's wildly
repetitive and the dinosaurs are window
dressing for multiple uninteresting
unrelated stories the actors do their
best but it's all just overindulgent and
pointless one of if not the worst in the
franchise it seems that many think the
story from trevorrow and derek connolly
tries to do too much but achieves
nothing by the end of the film which is
definitely disappointing meanwhile
variety in the av club critic courtney
howard tore into the film by saying it
doesn't follow the concept it's selling
the audience to instead focus on other
and less engaging storylines she tweeted
it ignores the premise it should have
had from the start instead synthetically
engineering two entirely different
uninteresting and hollow stories that it
struggles to connect this is a sentiment
echoed by thrilla's critic esther
zuckerman who simply says jurassic world
dominion is easily one of the stupidest
movies i've ever seen
see not so bad
but not everyone is feeling so negative
about the film some critics think it's a
unique adventure with interesting ideas
pandango's eric davis noted how
impressed he was with the horror-tinged
dinosaur scenes which is always great to
hear since steven spielberg's original
movie had its fair share of scares the
critic also praised the increased
presence of jeff goldblum's iconic ian
malcolm while noting that the movie
achieves in being in his words a solid
finale that's a vastly different
reaction to those calling it the worst
of the franchise but davis isn't the
only one who is hugely impressed with
the sequel gliders perry nemeroff noted
that she loves how priced alice howard
gets much more to do this time around
saying jurassic world dominion rocks an
excellent mix of practical and digital
effects dinos look great that metrodon
scene is right up my alley christ alice
howard runs away with the movie and new
trilogy for that matter claire
experiences one heck of an arc and
howard soars with it in fact variety's
jazz 10k thinks the film masterfully
uses the original trio to its advantage
while balancing the fine line in
nostalgic crowd pleasing she tweeted
it's non-stop dinosaur action and laura
dern jeff goldblum and sam neal's return
hit the nostalgic spots i just love them
whether jurassic world dominion will
divide fans as much as it has with
critics remains to be seen it's entirely
possible that audiences will be more
receptive to the adventure because of
the dyno action rather than looking for
well-plotted character arcs one thing's
for sure no matter what the critics
think it'll probably do just fine at the
box office
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]